Once users have accessed
your homepage or
your application, you'll likely want
the user to register for an account.
But this isn't always the case.
You should keep in mind that
registration doesn't have to be the next
immediate step in your process.
You should think carefully about
the entire user experience,
the product you're offering, and
when you want registration to happen, if
you want registration to happen at all.
Registration on Udacity's site is fairly
simple with just a couple fields or
you could also login using Facebook or
Google.
For more detailed
examples of sign ups and
onboarding, check out useronboard.com,
which is linked in the instructor notes.
You can walk through examples such as,
Gmail to see all the design elements
that guide first time users.
These details include animations
text annotations, tool tips, and
cause to action, all of these lead the
user to successfully using the product
for the first time.
Now, there are many ways to build out
a successful onboarding experience.
And our best piece of advice is
to test your ideas with users
using wireframes and mockups.
We'll cover how you can do this with
a design sprint in the next lesson.
To get a real sense of
why testing is important,
check out this article
about Yammer sign up flow.
The company found very
counter-intuitive results by adding
just one step to the registration flow.